First of all, you have to ask yourself the question, why are you taking protein powder?
So that'd be my first question to anybody who's asking a question about protein powder.
Why do you feel like you need to take protein powder? You know, I personally have never
felt like I needed to take protein powder. And protein powder is not the thing that's going to
make you gain weight. You don't gain weight because you eat a lot of protein.
If the only reason I would think that a cancer patient should take protein powder is if they're
getting a lot of muscle loss. So if they're in a cacacic state and they're getting a lot of muscle
loss, then taking a protein powder might be a good option to do. So if they're not getting muscle
loss, then I don't think if you're eating well, then you don't really need a protein powder.
Remember, if you're getting muscle loss, you have to watch my video on cacacia and look at the
blog post on cacacia because you need to be doing some weights. You need to be stimulating muscle growth.
So muscle is only going to grow when you ask something of it, when you're calling action of that
muscle, which is you're using it. So if I'm so sick that I'm just laid in bed and can't do anything,
you're going to have muscle atrophy. Even if you're taking protein powder, you're still going to have
muscle atrophy. So the only way that you could not have muscle atrophy is you need to use the muscle.
So you could be using the muscle and lifting weights and still have muscle atrophy,
you're still losing muscle cells because you have caccia. The cancers just gobbling up anything you
have. That's when it to me is appropriate to take protein powder. So if you're just taking,
you just have surgery, then you're going to be on a protein powder. And still I wouldn't. If you're
still, if you're eating well, if you're eating fish, if you're eating meat, if you're a vegan,
you're not getting any vegetable protein either, well, then maybe you have to because you're on a diet
that's restricting protein, then it's maybe appropriate, but it then try to defeat the purpose of
your diet and restricted protein if you're taking protein powder. So but if you're still just trying
to, oh, I'm just trying to restrict animal proteins, well, then I can't get enough in my diet,
a vegetable protein. So I'm trying to take protein powder. Well, I guess there's reasons for this.
So you got to everybody's different. You got to weigh this on.
weigh this on. He had muscle loss. This was before the treatment, we have to start from square one
once he could eat solid food again. That's right. So he can't eat that. So you're getting protein
through a powder. I would look at the US enzymes protein, has a much lower
biotabic acid content.